i think one of the things the pandemic
revealed is the huge gaping hole in so
many of our health care systems that we
do not provide health mental health
support for doctors and nurses we just
don't have it
one reason is the way hospitals are led
they're led very often more like
businesses and and providing mental
support mental health support for
doctors nurses and staff is on the l
side of the p l um and i think it's it's
just a gaping hole that we have to fill
which these are high stress jobs um and
even in the best of times it's still a
high stress job and there should be
services provided by every hospital
that have staff they're not for the
patients that staff there simply to take
care of the doctors nurses and staff who
are on the front lines good whether
there's a pandemic or not and the fact
that we hadn't invested in it means that
those resources were not available when
we needed the most
even the military in the united states
has a
mental health units that deploy
with their doctors and nurses into
combat zones because the stress is so
high so if the military is doing it and
understands it why aren't we doing it in
civilian hospitals so that's number one
uh number two um you know it's it's
about taking care of each other and and
this is in these difficult times one of
the funny things about high stress is is
high stress sometimes brings people
together shared hardship releases
oxytocin shared hardship shared struggle
actually creates very deep strong bonds
of trust the friendships that i'm sure
that they're building are actually
probably deeper than they ever thought
they'd ever build with their colleagues
in the past they're becoming their new
families and so there's huge
opportunities for socializing i'm sure
there's lots of gallows humor um uh but
the important thing is that they can
that they can disconnect as a group that
they can socialize um
anytime that they can have rest together
and interact and play games all of that
stuff really really matters and then
there's also the opportunity to you know
i'm you just said it holly be the leader
you wish you had
leadership fundamentally is the
responsibility to see those around us
rise and one of the best ways to deal
with our own stresses and strains is
actually to help others who are dealing
with the same stresses and strains
when i wrote leaders eat last i had the
opportunity to learn more about
alcoholics anonymous and alcoholics
anonymous like other 12-step programs
know
that we most of us know the first step
which is admitting you have a problem
but most of them know that it's the 12th
step that matters most
that if you master all 11 steps and not
the 12th you're probably more likely to
succumb to the disease but if you master
the 12 step you're more likely to
overcome the disease the 12th step is to
help another alcoholic service and so if
there is somebody who's really
struggling with their mental and missing
their families and the stress and strain
of being on the front lines then the
amazing thing is it's our opportunity to
help them that we're actually more
likely to help ourselves service service
to each other and even if we're
exhausted even if we're absolutely
exhausted to be open and honest to say
i'm exhausted and i need help and i know
from talking to friends who are doctors
and nurses
in covet wards that in many hospitals
admitting weakness or saying you're
exhausted or asking for help is a big
no-no because of the culture that they
have
and i think that's a huge opportunity
for for people to be more vulnerable
about their own needs and desire for
help and need for help
and the person who goes first is the
leader because the person who goes first
will set the tone someone else will try
and someone else will try and before you
know it you haven't you have a lot more
honesty and people asking for for help
who really need it rather than hiding it
um it's a it's a great question my my
big fear is that in care the problem is
not over that when coveted when when
finally the coveted numbers come down
um that there will be so much exhaustion
and burnout that we're going to lose a
lot of people who from the profession
and we'll have a void of doctors and
nurses uh in general um and so i think i
think this is still yet to come and
again it goes back to building up those
mental health units to support people
along the way not waiting for the next
the next emergency to happen